- [Peter] Hi everybody.
Thanks for being here.
We know that investing in travel
and investing in being
here is no small thing.
So welcome to Las Vegas.
Welcome to re:Invent.
We know that customers
have this expectation
around where their data is,
and ISVs have this insane
covenant that you are holding
and handling customer data
on behalf of that customer.
And if you're doing it on AWS,
there are some very definite ways
to not only secure customer data,
but to provide the necessary assurances
and transparency so that customers
can form independent opinions
that you're doing the
right thing in over time.
My name is Peter O'Donnell.
I'm a principal solutions architect.
I've been with Amazon Web Services
for just about 10 and a half years.
This is my 12th re:Invent
and I'm joined today by Jenn
Reed, another principal SA
who covers one of our largest
and most strategically critical ISVs.
So we're gonna talk a little bit
about what this means to protect data
and where cryptography
plays a role in that
and the history of what
it means to manage keys.
We have come a long way from
very expensive, hard to manage,
cumbersome, single tenant, gigantic HSMs
that live in your own building
to a much more flexible
cloud-like capability.
With AWS KMS, our key management service,
which does still indeed have
very expensive HSMs behind it.
We talk about why customers care
about bringing their own
key and what BYOK means.
'Cause as it turns out, we've overloaded
that term in our history.
We talk about two different
ways of approaching
what it means to protected
secure customer data
with customer keys.
And then finally, Jenn's
gonna show you some
really neat software, some
code that we've developed
to give you an example and a taste
for what it takes to
implement these things.
So I mentioned that we've
overloaded the term BYOK.
In the beginning we had a very large
and important financial services customer
who demanded that we create something
that was a "big red
button" in their words.
And this became a feature
known as import key material.
If you're familiar with
KMS, there's this idea
of a customer managed key, a CMK.
And you think about it as
a key and it has a key ID
and it even has an ARN,
an Amazon resource name.
But the CMK is not the actual key.
The key is a notional construct.
And there is in fact
key material within it.
The original BYOK feature allowed you
to import your own key
material into that thing.
And that was actually
not the interesting part.
The interesting part is
that we allow you to burn
that key material instantaneously
while keeping the construct of the CMK.
That allows a customer to
hit that big red button,
remove the key material
from inside of that CMK,
but later reimport it and
undo that big red button.
What we're primarily talking
about today when we say BYOK
is allowing customers to
have their own key material
and their own key to protect their data.
And that is the high order tenet.
The high order tenet is that customer data
ought to be protected by customer keys.
This is the expectation
that the engineers have.
that the executives have.
This is the expectation that regulators
and other third party
stakeholders may have.
It's a very simple, straightforward idea.
If it's customer data,
it should be protected
with customer keys.
And indeed we take that
tenet very seriously
in our own services when
we store and process data
on your behalf across
dozens and dozens and dozens
of such services, from
databases to file systems,
to the object store and everything else,
we allow our customers to protect
their data with their keys
in some as ISVs, same covenant,
same set of expectations
for largely the same reasons.
So Slack was one of the first big ISVs
that really got this right.
And you could imagine
if you've used Slack,
and we certainly do,
there's a lot of
confidential stuff in Slack,
whether it's messages,
the contact data itself, exchanging files.
And of course Slack these days can do lots
of other really interesting
collaboration things.
But this idea of what it
means to have your own key
is often perceived differently
by different customers.
We generally take it to mean
that it's a customer CMK,
in a customer account that is shared
cross account to the ISV to make use of,
and that's what we're gonna talk about.
So when customers think
about this problem, right,
I think it's important as
ISVs that you understand
where they are coming from
and why they are asking this of you.
"I need to have my keys protect my data."
And I mentioned this idea
of the big red button.
That because of this strange
role where you are handling
and processing customer
data on their behalf,
that's core to your business,
it's a covenant of trust.
But customers still
will very often believe
that they need a big red button
so that if you have an event
or they spill something
into your software,
which depending on what
you're using, if it's logging,
everybody who's in the logging business
should know about log spills.
The customer will want a mechanism,
a mechanism to immediately
disable access to that data.
And that's the big red button.
But there's also dimensions of assurance
that are required here.
Customers want to observe
how you are using the
key material over time
and how you are implementing the covenant
of what you agreed to on paper
or what you agreed to in a meeting.
And that's also part of what it means
to let them use their own key.
On AWS, we log almost all
of our APIs into CloudTrail.
And I say almost all
because there are data plane events in S3,
that's actually something
you have to go turn on.
But KMS logs everything, all encrypt,
decrypt generate data key, describe key,
there's a bunch of other
APIs, are in CloudTrail.
What's interesting about KMS
is that if you use it cross account
that a calling principle
in one account using S3
but references a key in another account,
we output two events, identical events,
but into two separate trails.
The trail of the calling principle,
which might be your ISV service account,
and the trail that belongs to the account
that holds the resource,
that is to say the key.
And customers really like this.
So you'll still have your own CloudTrail
where you can see your
use of the customer's key,
but because the key
belongs to the customer
in the other account, they
will get corresponding
CloudTrail records as well.
And this is very important.
I mentioned, you know, this
idea of the big red button,
but disabling and revoking
access, customers want to be able
to also control the lifecycle of that key,
maybe give you a new key
after a period of time.
By thinking of this way
and building the support into
your products from the outset,
you can support that.
Oh, we're gonna start
using a different key.
Sure, go into those settings control panel
and change the ARN of the key
and of course make sure
you properly authorize it.
And there's also a
compliance dimension to this.
Whether it's compliance
with an external entity
like a regulator or anything else,
or even just internal controls compliance,
that being able to protect
the data is not enough,
you also must be able to tell that story
and provide assurances over time.
In the international market,
the idea of data sovereignty
becomes even more important,
especially in Europe now
and increasingly in
jurisdictions all over the world.
There is again this heightened
emphasis on the core tenet
that my data should be
protected with my keys
and that can help lead to
data sovereignty outcomes.
And third party
stakeholders also love this.
The beginning of my career I
worked for a very large bank
through AWS, I worked for AWS,
but they were by big baby, my customer.
And they made a clear decision early on
that all data in the
cloud would be encrypted.
Today that's a very normal thing to say.
10 years ago it was actually
pretty revolutionary
that they were gonna A,
move a bank system of
record to the cloud at all
and B, demand that ubiquitous encryption.
But today this is table stakes.
And if your product doesn't
support these capabilities,
there will be customers who will see that
as a gating decision, a
purchasing gating decision
that if they can't have
their data protected
by their keys, they might not buy.
So the motivation for
you is, as I just said,
that this is table stakes.
Having been here since 2015,
I can tell you when this
wonderful customer of mine,
of ours, first said this,
ubiquitous encryption was a big idea.
We didn't really have ubiquitous
encryption at the time,
in 2015.
Today we do.
But that also means that
your products must as well.
And even if you support encryption,
you need to be able to tell a rich story
that if it's just an encrypted file system
and there is no separate authorization
once the file system is mounted,
that that may not solve your
customer's requirements either.
Now the good news is customers
tend to trust AWS KMS.
I can tell you firsthand,
a lot of the first part
of my career here was
explaining to customers
how KMS worked, explaining
to them the HSMs,
the design of the HSMs,
our regulatory position
as it regards FIPS or anything else.
And now customers generally support KMS.
They like its characteristics,
they like that it comes from us,
they like that it's FIPS validated now
with the 140-3, which is the new program
that succeeded dash two and level three.
And if you're not a FIPS
nerd, it doesn't matter.
Just know that those are the
table stakes, but we have it.
But achieving this kind
of compliance coverage
is really critical for customers,
especially as they tell their own story.
Their data that they are
holding is protected by KMS.
Why wouldn't their data
that you are holding
also meet that same bar?
Now what's cool is that
KMS is really flexible
and it's lovely and it integrates
with all of our managed services
and you can integrate it
with your own software.
In the second part of the presentation
Jenn will kind of show you what that means
because we have built
some really nice SDKs
to make this easier for you.
An SDK for database services
that even allows a little bit of searching
over encrypted data in Dynamo,
and an SDK for just general encryption.
So general client side encryption,
whether it's a blob or anything else.
We've got some SDKs
that integrate with KMS,
but they certainly don't lock you into it.
One thing that Jenn will show you
is that you have alternatives
for the key provider.
Again, it works out of the box with KMS,
but if you wanna hook
it up to something else,
you certainly can.
And so KMS solves a lot
of problems for you.
The soul of what we do here at AWS
is what we call
undifferentiated heavy lifting.
And so we've already figured
out how to scale KMS,
how to keep it healthy.
It is our highest level of SLA.
We deliver KMS at a SLA of five nines.
And in fact the reality is significantly
more available than that.
There's already transparent
rotation built into KMS
where we will increment
the underlying key material
and just a lot of genuine
value that comes from the fact
that you're integrating with KMS.
So there are a couple of
different kinds of KMS
that all has a top layer, the KMS APIs.
Then there's a second layer,
which is where the keys actually live.
The best solution for
effectively all customers
is regular KMS where the key
material is both generated
within and used for
cryptographic operations
within KMS multi-tenant HSMs.
And again, these things are the real deal.
They are bespoke, they're
built to our design
and they are FIPS validated.
And point in fact, the
entire box is FIPS validated.
It's not just a little widget
inside of a plain vanilla server.
The entire widget is a
validated FIPS module.
But there are some alternatives
that will be relevant for your customers.
I mentioned earlier that
the original definition
of BYOK allowed for imported key material.
We call this an imported
CMK, where the CMK,
the construct, exists at the KMS API,
but the key material is
injected by the customer.
Some customers came to us and said,
"Well I can't quite convince everybody
that a multi-tenant HSM is a good idea.
I think it is and I'm
an expert in this stuff.
But sometimes people are like,
what do you mean a multi-tenant HSM?"
And so we offered an alternative.
We have a cloud HSM product
that is in fact a single tenant HSM
and you can graft that thing
onto the top layer of KMS
and that's called custom key store.
And it does exactly what it says.
If you've got a stakeholder
or a customer stakeholder
who absolutely can't
accept using a regular KMS,
you can hook cloud HSM up
to it and get that outcome.
We built another thing
that we're sure we don't
think anybody should use,
but we built it because
customers demanded it of us,
which is practically the
reason we build anything.
And that's called XKS,
the external key store.
This allows for sometimes
what you will hear
referred to as HYOK, hold your own key.
The cool part about
the cloud is that we do
all of the impossible part,
from the ground to the concrete,
to locking the doors at night,
all the way up to the stack.
Some customers, whether
because the requirement
is placed upon them by a third party
or because there's somebody
in the security org
that needs a warm blanket,
which is an okay reason,
believe that that key
needs to live in a building
that they control.
It needs to be in my house.
Like all right, we'll
build it and we built it.
This allows you to have an HSM
that lives in your own office building
but is hooked up to the front end of KMS
and that's called XKS.
Probably don't let people do this.
It comes with scaling,
it comes with availability characteristics
that are gonna be radically different
than good old regular KMS
where we do the scaling
and the availability for you.
But it is out there.
But the good news is as you
build to integrate it with KMS,
your customers still get
all this flexibility.
That you yourself as the ISV,
don't really need a
reason about this part,
but it will be relevant
for the conversation.
So let's do a quick primer.
I think a lot of people think
they know what encryption is,
but as it turns out, encrypting
data is the easy part.
All you gotta do is combine
a data key with data
and then you get ciphered
data, encrypted data.
That is categorically the easy part.
That's what you're probably already doing.
But the problem is what do
I do with this data key?
Where do I put it? How do
I keep it safe over time?
And the answer is that
you combine that data key
with another key and you encrypt
the key with a different key.
This is known as wrapping.
Wrapping like a present.
So you're gonna wrap that
data key with the KMS key
and now you have an encrypted data key.
So where do you store that?
Well, as it turns out, the right place
to store it is just store
it with the encrypted data.
You store the data encryption key,
I'm gonna start calling that a DEK.
You store the DEK wrapped with the top key
that lives in KMS and
you put it in one package
and then you put it
somewhere safe like S3.
The question is, "Well you told me Pete
start with the DEK.
You got a data encryption key,
then you gotta protect
that with another key.
Great. Is it turtles all the way down.
What do I do with the KMS key?"
And that's where we come
in. We do the rest of it.
And if you wanna learn about
all the full key hierarchy of
KMS, you can find that online.
It's actually a pretty interesting story.
We take care of all that other hard part.
And of course we protect
your KMS keys at rest
by encrypting them again.
And then there's a whole thing
and it kind of is
turtles all the way down,
but it ends in, you
know, printed out paper
that if we ever lost curb power,
we could turn the stack of
turtles back on the hard way.
We've never had that, knock wood,
but we do have a plan for that.
And so that's what the
perimeter for encryption is.
We call this pattern of unique DEKs
that protect data with DEKs
that are then protected
by a high order key, envelope encryption.
And this is the way
all of it works at AWS,
and this is the way you
should probably do it as well.
And Jenn's gonna talk about
this idea of a key ring,
about starting your own key hierarchy
with a key that you get out of KMS.
So that all sounds great.
Now we know why customers care.
We know what they're looking for
and we kind of understand, okay,
envelope encryption, how do you do it?
How should a customer let
you use their key material
to integrate with your
software to protect their data
that is in your hands?
There's a couple simple ways to do this.
If you're just writing objects into S3,
just do cross account key sharing.
End of list.
But if you're holding
a multi-tenant database
with individual customer records,
it's a lot more complicated
than just give me the ARN.
And depending on the nature of your ISV,
if you've got your own data plane
and it's not just a relational database
but perhaps a much more complex data plane
that is itself probably multi-tenant.
Now you've got some very
interesting complexities,
complexities around availability,
complexities around persistence.
'Cause the only thing
worse than losing data
is losing a key 'cause losing a key
is like losing data, except even harder.
So how do customers share
their keys with you?
So there's three ways to do this.
If what you're doing is
primarily just interacting
with AWS resources, that is
to say you're not in the weeds
of your own data plane and
a multi-tenant data plane.
Just do it cross account resource sharing.
It's one of the oldest
tricks from the IAM book.
You write a resource policy
that goes on the key,
we call that a key policy.
And you delegate effectively,
a service principle
that belongs to you, the ISV.
So service.acmecorp.com
is allowed to call for encrypt, decrypt,
generate data key and describe key.
That's the simplest part.
Some customers think well
or some ISVs think "Well
no, what I really want,
what I really wanna do is
assume one of their roles
and then use that to access the key."
No, why would you do that? Don't do that.
Just do cross account resource sharing.
Now sometimes vendors are like,
"Oh well I'll call this BYOK
and I'll have all the key material
and there's a key for Alice
and there's a key for Bob."
But it's not really bring
your own key if you do that.
Customers don't get the logging visibility
that we talked about.
They certainly don't get
the big red button that we talked about.
And so your customer's level of trust
in the eventual solution that you're going
to market with can be greatly affected
by the choices that you make here.
We want you to be successful,
we really want our customers
to be successful and you
guys are our customers.
But often your customers are
also somehow our customers.
And so we want you to
do this the right way,
which is why we're here having this talk.
So as it turns out,
cross account key sharing
is really straightforward.
Resources on AWS have
their own policy document
called a resource policy.
And when you're talking about S3,
it's often referred to as a bucket policy.
If you're talking about KMS,
it's called a key policy.
And as it turns out, this
is really straightforward.
Statement, allow principle
that belongs to Acme Corp.
Action, encrypt, decrypt,
generate data key and describe key.
Pretty straightforward stuff.
It's key to understand, haha pun,
it's essential to understand
that you're only going to get authorized
for the cryptographic operations.
That you do not need and
nor should you ask for
other actions on the key.
Those ought to belong to the
key owner, your customer.
'Cause some of those actions
could be really powerful.
Disable does exactly what it sounds like.
You don't need the ability to
call for disable on the key
and you should not ask for it.
There's a couple of other
very powerful actions.
Put key policy.
You do not need that and
nor should you ask for it.
And perhaps most powerful of all,
there's an API called
schedule key deletion.
We don't actually let
you delete it right away
'cause that's a very serious foot gun.
But schedule key deletion,
you do not need it
and you should not ask for it.
All you need is very simple.
Write on the key, encrypt, decrypt,
generate data key and describe key.
Now how do you get this going?
How do you kind of bootstrap
this new customer onboarding?
It's probably enough to
just publish some JSON.
This is what it needs to look like.
Copy and paste it on your key policy.
Your sales engineers can probably
do this for your customer
during onboarding or ramping or whatever.
You could probably give
them some cloud formation
which would create a key
and then put the right policy on it.
And lots of other ways
to think about this.
You wanna give 'em a terraform
thing? Sure, whatever.
But you should be reasoning about this
'cause it's essential that your customers
not only get it right so they can start
receiving the benefit of your software.
It would be dumb to delay time to value
just because it takes a week to figure out
what to put on the key policy.
And you want your
customers to get it right
for safety and security.
Because if they give you allow KMS star,
you now have too much ability
for all the things I just talked about.
Schedule key deletion,
disable, put key policy.
Don't let them give you
KMS star on the key policy.
Only take the actions you need.
Everybody knows the
phrase least privilege.
Make sure you get least privilege.
So there's a couple different
patterns, ultimately.
What I just described
is really simple stuff.
Like if I'm gonna put an object in S3
and I wanna protect it by your key,
all I have to say is put
object, dash, dash key ID.
But there are some more interesting
and complex ways to do this
in this idea of a data key broker.
Where you're gonna start
your own key hierarchy
from the customer's KMS key.
And then as you say, ingest log files
or create, you know, whatever kind of unit
of entity in your data plane.
You can take that envelope
encryption pattern
and add one more layer.
So it's KMS key to customer key,
customer key to data keys.
And you can add one more layer too,
depending on what makes
the most sense for you.
And this effectively,
again, is a key hierarchy.
And the data key broker pattern here
is a simple way to do that.
So as customers upload data,
there is certainly this
idea of crypto wear out.
You don't want to use a single DEK,
a single data encryption key
for a colossal body of data
that's got blast radius problems.
And at hyperscale there's a theoretical
crypto analytic problem with that.
Like if you go and
create petabytes of data
with a single DEK, it
creates an entry point
for an adversary to do
something like reverse the key.
It's very easy to avoid that
by not encrypting everything
with a single data encryption key.
And the workflow kind of looks like this.
I don't know how visible this is to you,
but you know these slides will eventually
get published on the internet.
But this is effectively
what the flow looks like
for this idea of the broker.
So there are some more
questions about this.
How do I request and
deal with the data keys?
How do I deal with multi-tenancy
and where does this kind of solve?
And again, this is where
our encryption SEKs come in,
they're open source, they're
available for a handful
of very popular languages,
Java, Python, things like that.
And it's awesome.
It does right what it says on the tin.
It's written by a group of experts
and it's open source so
you can understand it
and reason about it and maybe
even improve it on your own.
For client side encryption,
there are a bunch of questions,
how do I properly implement it?
What modes should I be using?
And again, the SDK is almost definitely
the right way to answer
all these questions.
The SDK has a message
format. It's pretty flexible.
You can even get multi-region resiliency
by either using multi-region keys,
which is a new thing we
introduced two, three years ago.
Or you just take the data
and the wrapped data key
and it's wrapped under
two different regions.
So if it's in Oregon, you
can unwrap the DEK in Oregon.
There's another version of the same DEK
that you can unwrap in Virginia.
There are two of these.
One is the general purpose ESDK.
This is suitable for blobs, right?
Whatever it is. A lump.
For database-specific applications,
particularly Dynamo,
which is probably the right
data store for most things.
But it certainly works with the
relational products as well.
The database-specific
SDK has some additional
considerations built into it.
And again, these are expert
level software packages.
They're both open source,
they're maintained
by a really brilliant group of people.
The ESDK is designed to
make it easy for portability
so that you can deal with these things.
There's again, a way to
register multiple key providers
so that if your customer expects you
to be available in both
Oregon and Virginia,
just as examples, that
there's a way to do that.
The single message format
makes it really easy
and high speed to deal with.
Mention this idea like where
do I store the wrapped key
and where do I store the encrypted data?
And I said the answer is put 'em together.
Well the ESDK does that.
It automatically puts them together.
And ultimately you kind of only need
to keep track of two things.
One that lump, the data,
and where the key is, the key provider,
which is not the DEK, 'cause
the DEK is with the lump,
the encrypted lump.
The key provider is, you know, which KMS?
The KMS in Virginia, KMS and Oregon.
'Cause of course like most things at AWS,
that will be region specific.
This is what that kind
of ends up looking like.
This is a little bit of an overview,
there's some details left out of this
for the simplicity of the diagram,
but this is basically
what that looks like.
That you call through to the ESDK.
The ESDK calls down to
the operating system
to get the right crypto.
Every operating system is
gonna know how to speak AESGCM,
which is an implementation of AES.
A mode.
And again, we get the blob that comes out,
that's in the lower right there,
where you get everything
necessary together.
I mentioned this idea of
a hierarchical key ring
and this is where I'm
gonna turn it over to Jenn.
There's a deep explanation of this
and practically everything I said
is examined very deeply
in our documentation.
So hopefully this is a pretty good primer.
This is a code talk
and I'm gonna turn it
over to my friend Jenn
who's gonna get into it.
Cheers.
Break a leg.
- [Jenn] I should not tape.
Okay.
Now for code.
Very good.
I hope everybody can see that pretty good.
Yep.
Visual Studio is your friend.
So how many people in
here understand Java?
Okay, so this will look familiar to you.
So this is basically a Java application
that was written called Beer Store,
which is an example application.
But what has been done here
is actually constructed it
to actually show the hierarchal key.
I wanted to start by just looking
at how those tenant data keys are created.
And then from that we'll take
a step back to understand
where that's stored in Dynamo
and where that's declared.
And then from a step back from
that, look at the actual KMS
so you can understand where the KMS ID
and those components are
configured and declared
that then get called down here.
But just so that you can
understand the context,
really seeing it from this perspective.
So if we look down here,
the most important part here is of course
you're gonna have KMS credentials,
of course, in this implementation.
So when you're onboarding a tenant,
each tenant's gonna get their own KMS ID,
their own client ID and credentials.
So this is so that each
one of your tenants,
will be able to understand
from a process perspective,
which one is used for which key.
Because for SaaS providers,
you wanna make sure each
customer that you have,
each tenant that you have
are actually being able
to manage their own keys
independently, not all on one cycle.
And we scroll down a
little bit further here
on that onboarding process.
Each of those is of course
gonna get a branch key
and then it's gonna have their credentials
within the application
that's going to call it.
And then when someone is offboarding,
because we are gonna cache those in Dynamo
and then they will age out.
So the caching in default
here is set to 15 minutes,
but it becomes deactivated
within the application.
They can no longer use it.
And then it comes out of
the Dynamo DV system itself.
So you can see that
thereafter it has expired.
And if we scroll down here, and of course
you're gonna see for the
rotation of each of the keys.
So of course if you're
going to have customers
managing their keys, you want them
to manage the rotation of those keys.
And each customer's going to, of course,
have different expectations of what
that rotation cycle should be,
based upon what their internal compliance
or security program requires
or compliance program requires.
Then scrolling down, we can see
how you might want to handle
multiple tenants data at a single time.
And so here's a key ring,
it's a multi-tenant key ring
handling multiple customers
at the same time, but each of
those are cached separately.
And each of those data streams,
one can't read the other
because each of those data streams,
even though it's being
handled by the same process,
each of those data streams
are only really readable
by the encryption and the
encryption key stored for it.
Make sense?
And then here at the very bottom
is if you have a customer,
and so you can support
both mechanisms because setting up
and establishing and maintaining KMS
can be a bit of a process bear.
From most customer's perspective,
when you're setting up key rings
and setting up those KMS keys,
holding them from a
multi-tenant perspective,
like the upper example here on 208,
makes a lot of sense.
But if you have a customer's like,
"No, I really want my KMS
to be in a single tenant
and it's only ever in the
process with only my data."
Then here's an example of
that just with a single tenant
within that key ring
being handled at one time.
So there's two ways of doing that.
Now, if we take a step
back, remember when I said
that in the Dynamo DB handle,
how that expiration works.
So here is actually setting
up that data key broker
for the Dynamo DB table.
And so you can see how each of
those for actually setting up
that those data objects is established.
And the important part down
here is really understanding
the coordination of those keys
for each tenant within Dynamo.
And then when you're
actually rotating them,
setting up your intermediate keys.
And then of course down here
is where you're actually
setting up your key ID
and the branch ID,
which is per each tenant
and then the encryption context
and the actual credential
provider that's being called
and can be defined in
the other Java object
we'll go into next.
And then for that branch key request,
how that's being called.
And once again just
explaining the default time,
which is here, how long you're
gonna hold on that delete.
In the actual sample
application it's 15 minutes.
It can be five minutes,
it can be one minute
how long you're gonna hold it cached.
And that caching will be,
if someone deletes it,
it will then no longer
be in Dynamo after that.
But it may mean that you're
going to make the request
to Dynamo more frequently
to refresh your cache.
So you have to hit that parameter
of how long do you wanna cache for,
'cause that will be when something
it's marked for deletion,
when it'll actually disappear from Dynamo.
But that also just means you have to
be querying Dynamo to
actually refresh your cache.
So it's really like what does
the application you're doing
and what does that mean
from a deletion perspective?
And letting that guide that.
Now if you have most of
your customers are happy
with say 15 minutes or five minutes,
but you have one customer
that it needs to be a minute,
then in that instance it might make sense
to have most of them under
the multi-tenant aspect
and then have the other one
on the single tenant aspect
that has that more reduced time phrase
so that you can handle their refresh
but not have to be refreshing
every tenant's keys at the same cycle.
Does that make sense to everyone?
Excellent.
So if we take a step back from that
to actually look at the KMS client.
So here you can actually see
how it's actually
establishing from the SDK
setting up the individual
KMS in keys, scrolling down,
that then the service
client will actually use
when the application is running.
Any questions?
It's pretty straightforward.
A lot of our security and
observability customers
use this as well as some
of our business apps.
So like Slack or Zoom and some others
also use the same sort of concept.
And really it's about how do I expose that
so the customer's providing
access appropriately to the KMS
so they're not having
to like plug in the ARN.
Peter was explaining earlier
how you can give them cloud
formation scripts to do that,
but on November 19th of this year,
pre re:Invent the IAM team announced
partner-managed delegated permissions.
Which actually makes
this a little bit easier
in the fact that within your
app, your SaaS application,
you can make a request via IAM.
Now in order to register,
you have to provide
policy boundary templates
that are approved
by AWS to the IAM team.
But what that is, is a scope down policy.
So then from your SaaS
platform, you can make a request
on the customer's behalf
to the administrator
or the user with the
appropriate permissions
into IAM for that administrator
to approve or deny.
And what that does is then from
then you can actually update
the permissions via cloud
formation or Terraform
leveraging that temporary delegation
to actually say deploy a role
or deploy sharing of KMS.
Right?
But it can only do that to
actually do it that one time.
But then after that point,
I know we talked about encrypt,
decrypt and generate key,
most observability and security providers
tend to just need decrypt
because they're not encrypting the key.
They want to decrypt it
so that they can read it
and then store it on their side
in the data store that they're using,
but they don't necessarily wanna wrap it
in an envelope on their side.
Then they make the request back
to actually read the data using your key.
So using that cross account role,
but they never want to do
actually any physical encrypting
or you wouldn't wanna do
any physical encrypting
of additional data because
that can be a bit risky,
or generate the keys using their key.
The customer should always
generate those keys.
So there are different
things you wanna think about
from your application's
perspective in the design.
What do you really need
and is it something you just
need in order to set up,
in which case you can use a
partner delegated permission
or request for a one-time action,
and then with permission boundaries.
Or is it something that
you're going to want
a general rule for encrypt
or decrypt or generate keys?
But there are ways you
can spread that out.
So at any one point in time you can give
that granular access to your customer.
But what I think is really powerful
is the ability for you to then make
those specific requests
and policy statements
so the customer can make those choices.
So you're not having the
friction of having them
go talk to the DevOps
person to provide the script
to the template to the right account.
It'll initiate it in
the appropriate account
for that appropriate
admin to approve or deny.
So I think combining these
capabilities together
gives you the ISV, the
ability to help customers
be able to bring their own keys
but do it in a way that
makes the most sense
and always encouraging our
ISV partners to build on AWS
so you can use KMS where appropriate.
And then still if the customer does have
an on-prem key store,
being able to access that
by leveraging the KMS
construct to import as well.
Any other questions?
Yes.
- [Audience Member] With branch keys,
do you see any pushback from customers
who are like super hyped
up on observability
where, you know, you're
kind of caching the key,
not showing every (indistinct) logging?
- [Peter] I think you can
have a patient conversation
with the customer to explain.
So the question there is
right with branch keys
because you're not going
back to KMS every time,
you're not gonna get KMS CloudTrail events
for all the cool things.
True.
I think customers, I'd like to believe,
maybe this is me being a
naive solutions architect
who always believes I could convince
someone of something if I'm right.
But the question is ultimately
if you want hyperscale
and performance, you can't emit logging
every time you touch something.
I think it shouldn't probably
be at the top of your list,
but you could admit your own logging.
- [Jenn] 100%
You should always prevent for
being providing the telemetry.
And those actions,
because it's also in here.
I scrolled past it,
but you're also logging
the number of times
your application's making use of that key.
And then of course that would be
emitted in your logs of your application.
- [Peter] But I would tell you, you know,
the question of caching anything is like,
'cause this also maybe undermines
the big red button, right?
If I'm caching, if I
invented a new top key
and I've got that clear top key,
the big red button goes away,
a lot of things go away.
Your colleagues in your security team
and your application security team
and the people that are
doing your SOC report
should all have strong
opinions about this, right?
Caching is one thing,
committing that top key
to non-volatile storage and clear, right?
There's a lot of things that
of course you should
not be doing, but yes.
- Yes.
- I just wanted to add (indistinct).
- [Peter] Kevin Lee, one of
the product managers for KMS.
- [Jenn] Yes.
(Kevin speaks indistinctly)
Make sure that you still
have permission (indistinct).
The time frame (indistinct)
- [Peter] Right. Yeah, that's
a really interesting point.
I think the point that
Kevin's making there
is that there are somewhat
out of band ways to check
to see if you still have the authorization
in the first place and you
could use that as a signal
to drop the cache.
Right. Did I repeat that back okay?
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
- [Jenn] I couldn't hear.
- [Peter] Should we do more questions?
- [Jenn] Yeah. Huh?
- [Peter] The question is
should we do more questions?
- [Jenn] Yeah, 100%. Ask your questions.
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
between security key and (indistinct)
outside organization
especially (indistinct).
Create your own key (indistinct)
Essentially (indistinct).
The only way you can provide true security
is you hold your own key. (indistinct)
- [Jenn] Well, I mean, so like you could,
that was one of the
examples that we showed
is you own your own key
and or hold your own key.
And here, each of the
processes has access to it,
but the admins don't have access
to the processes themselves.
- [Peter] Well said.
- [Jenn] (laughs) So it's kind
of, it's one of these things
that, it might be a digression,
but I happen to do it a lot.
It's when we're talking
about AI and agents,
people like to think of them as people
and I beg you stop
thinking of them that way.
Think of them as processes.
Right?
And if you think about them as processes
because that's what they
are, then it's making sure
that only that process ever
has access to that component.
And how do I architect
a solution to ensure
that process only has access
to that data and those keys
and another process never has it
nor can it hand the data over.
- [Peter] Right.
I mean the notional idea
of ownership, right?
Without pulling apart the
ontological concept of ownership.
If it's the customer's key
and the customer's account,
that to me is as strong
of an ownership model
as if it's in their own building.
You know, I work here but
I'm very passionate about it.
You own your data.
So if you put an object into S3,
is it any less yours
than if that same file
was in a file system in your building?
No, it's absolutely still yours.
I think XKS is, I kind kidded that earlier
is a warm blanket,
but to me it is still
very much your own key
if it is in your account
and the ISV has cross
account authorization
to make use of it.
- [Audience Member] My main point is
it doesn't give you extra
security. (indistinct)
Doesn't it's secure. (indistinct)
- [Peter] But that's a path that leads to,
well you don't own your own data
if you're hiring an ISV
to process the data.
And that can't be true.
'Cause then none of you
would have businesses, right?
Like, so the boundaries of ownership
to my taste are if
you're accepting the idea
that you're gonna hire an ISV
to do stuff with your data,
you are already through
that looking glass.
You are already asking
them to touch your data.
- [Jenn] And that's also
where you start to say,
make sure if they're gonna do
any processing on that data,
what security and compliance
have they gone through?
- Right.
- You know,
do they have ISO certification?
Do they have-
- A competent SOC 2 program?
- Correct.
- Yeah.
- [Jenn] I like to go further than SOC 2,
but to each their own.
- Sure.
But table sticks. Table sticks.
- [Jenn] Because what that does
is you have a third party auditor
coming in and validating those controls
that are put into place
- [Peter] That's right.
- [Jenn] That they're handling the data
and making sure that the
employees never have access
and the processes themselves
never write out data,
and not any of that activity is logged in,
which you have that telemetry.
- [Peter] Yeah, but I
think I heard you say
for so long as the ISV has the
authorization to use the key,
you've got a security problem.
I can't accept that.
'Cause again, I hired
the ISV to touch my data.
- [Jenn] Right.
And also that's why I was saying
it depends on what your
application's doing.
So if I'm writing something
and I only ever write,
then I should only have encrypt, right?
On behalf of the customer.
- [Peter] And generate data key.
- [Jenn] Right. And generate the key.
If all I'm ever doing is
reading it from say you're a sim
or detection and response,
I should only ever be able to read it.
- Right.
- I should never be able
to actually write it or generate
a key for it.
- That's a great point.
- [Jenn] And so making
sure that you understand
what the action is
and making sure that you don't
give permission beyond that
and there's an appropriate
permission boundary
in place in addition to those things.
- [Peter] Well said.
- Yes. Oh yeah 100%.
- [Audience Member] So how do you deal
with different customers
with different requirements?
I get that some customers are gonna be,
"Oh, I wanna hold my own key.
I want to do it in KMS
and I'm an avid AWS user."
So that's fine.
While others are gonna be, "I don't know
what you're talking about
and I don't use AWS.
I don't have an account."
How do you usually deal with that.
- [Peter] I think my short
answer to that is build to KMS
and if customers wanna hold their own key,
there's a way to do that with KMS.
- [Jenn] Right. And and
it's abstracted from you.
- [Peter] Right.
- [Audience Member] Does that impact
how you interact with the APIs?
- [Peter] It doesn't change
any of the API contracts.
XKS, the external key store
where it lives in an HSM
in your office building or data center.
It does have implications
for performance. Right?
If you're operating a petascale data lake
with 1,000 nodes banging on it.
- And globally,
- Right.
And you have to go back
to the HSM every time.
- Or you have to go to an on-prem HSM
going for a network connection
and you have a really small caching time.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- [Jenn] I mean this is where
it starts to become important.
The caching discussion.
Just like in for a
database itself, you know,
you sometimes have to cache the
most frequently asked things
and that's why you set a time to live.
Same thing for DNS.
You set time to live
because I need to cache the
fully qualified domain names.
Now if I have very dynamic IPs
for load balancers and things like that,
my time to live is probably in seconds.
Right?
But if I'm sitting at the
top of the name space,
my time to live might be 24 hours.
- Right.
- Right?
And so it's really understanding
that from a KMS perspective
and architecting that in
a way that makes sense
based upon where the customer determines
where they want to,
how long and where it's being stored
and you as the provider.
That's why I'm saying like it might be
for that really particular customer,
it's that bottom example.
And that time to live has to
be longer because it's on-prem.
And I have to take into effect the fact
that every time I clear my cache,
I'm gonna have to pull it back
and then I need to make sure
it's distributed, right?
And so I have to architect
to account for that.
- [Peter] But to summarize the answer,
the characteristic of the
key, XKS, custom key store,
regular KMS, does not
change API interactions.
- [Jenn] It doesn't. Yeah.
- [Peter] It can change
performance characteristics.
And availability
characteristics of the results.
- 100%.
That's why I'm saying that
the multi-tenant one above,
most of the time that makes sense.
Right?
If I have one that then is
that particular customer
is gonna be on-prem,
they wanna hold their own key,
I am not having that
impact the other tenants.
Does that make sense?
- [Audience Member] Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. (indistinct)
Probably on the onboarding side
there's gonna be lots
of different processes
for different requirements.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And onboarding a new client.
- [Jenn] Yeah.
Yes.
- I have a question.
- Please.
- [Audience Member] So I'm used
to thinking in terms of data
and key encrypt.
So now my data's encrypted.
We talked about rotation (indistinct)
and I'm having trouble getting past that.
That hurdle of now I've
got a petabyte of data
that's been encrypted.
- [Peter] So we are very opinionated about
what rotation is and what it is not.
A lot of people think of
rotation as if I rotate,
then I'm gonna destroy the previous key,
which necessitates
re-encrypting all the data
so that it's now protected by the new key.
That is not how we do it.
Historically, again, I'm very
opinionated bit about this.
So let me get through this quickly.
Historically you rotated for two reasons.
Number one, humans had access to it.
And now that human left the building.
We don't have that problem with KMS.
Nobody ever touches
those keys. Not even us.
There is no way for us to
access your key material.
The other reason you
rotate is crypto wear out.
I used the same key for all this data
and now I need another one.
The envelope encryption pattern
addresses both problems.
That the blast radius of an individual key
is necessarily very, very narrow,
'cause it's typically per
resource or per file or whatever.
And there is no such thing as
getting the key out of KMS.
Like there's no API
to dematerial.
- You can't export.
- [Peter] And even if you could,
you couldn't make use of it.
What we do when we rotate
is, I mentioned earlier
that the idea of the CMK, the ARN
is itself effectively a vessel,
inside of that is the real key material.
If you turn on rotation
on a periodic basis,
I think by default a year.
And did we ever lower the
period for that? We did?
- 30 days to 7 years.
- There you go.
30 days to 7 years.
This whole week there's
gonna be new things.
And it's hard for us too.
At that rotation period
we create new key material
that will be used for future encrypt
and generate data key events.
We keep the old key material.
Because if we didn't, we would have
to go re-encrypt a giant body
of data, which is expensive
and time consuming and
really hard to get right
because of edge cases.
And if we got rid of the key material,
it would be very dangerous.
So when we rotate, we just
generate new key material
that is used for new
cryptographic operations,
but we keep the old one.
- [Jenn] Right.
And it's really important because if ever,
that's why the retention for seven years,
is if you ever have to go back in time
to go look at data from a period of time
where it was previously written,
you need to be able to read that.
- [Peter] That's right.
- [Jenn] And so that might be something
that's historically stored in Glacier,
but it's still attached to that older key
for when it was created.
So then when you need to access it,
you as the owner of it
when the application's
making the call can still,
it can go look back on that point in time.
- [Peter] But let me restate the two big
punchlines though to this topic.
Number one, the envelope
encryption pattern
takes away-
- All that complexity.
- [Peter] Off the table the reasons
to even think about rotation ever.
Full stop.
Number two, we have a rotation thing
that you can turn on and
make somebody in audit happy.
- [Jenn] And you don't need to worry about
how do I then go back in time
and use the key that
goes back and does that.
It's being taken care of for you.
- [Peter] Right.
But if you encounter a colleague who says,
"No, we need new data encryption keys
and we're gonna rewrap
and rekey all the data."
That person is wrong.
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
So what I'm asking is (indistinct).
So what is the solution
for that? (indistinct)
- [Peter] So what I think I heard was
you've got a kind of set of
competing interests, right?
You want to encrypt everything,
but there are trade-offs
that you want to work around.
Let's talk about some of those trade-offs.
The classic one is searching, right?
That's the biggest problem.
If I wanna have a column
in a relational data store
of taxpayer ID, social security
number in this country.
But I also wanna look up
customers by taxpayer.
It's not a great way to do that.
There are vanguard, cutting edge
homomorphic encryption options
that are just finally starting
to really become real.
There were some talks this week.
We hired a trio of cryptographers,
this lovely interesting group of people
that have worked together for 20 years.
Tal Rabin, Hugo,
I'm gonna blank on their
names, which is embarrassing.
- [Jenn] There's people
like Robert Alcorn and Avni
over on the crypto team.
- [Peter] Yeah.
But the searchable encryption
thing is out there.
You can kind of search across
encrypted fields these days.
It's not super high performance.
I wouldn't put it in the hot path
for a really high TPS application.
But there are some ways to do that.
Deterministic encryption for
particularly narrow key spaces
like a social security number,
like a credit card number,
can be super dangerous
because social security
numbers are super predictable.
If you know when and
where someone was born,
you've already lost half of
the social security number,
it's very predictable.
Same with credit card numbers.
Because of CVV too, there's
like an internal check sum
to the format of a credit card number
and the first six digits belong to banks.
And so the key spaces get
really narrow really fast,
which means it's trivial
to create a rainbow table
of all possible values.
So you gotta be very careful
at deterministic encryption.
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
It's getting there. It's getting there.
But again, the larger the field is
and if the cardinality of the field blooms
like a free text field, then
all the promises fall apart.
If the cardinality of
the encrypted payload
that you're attempting to search across
is relatively finite, the
solution works much better.
But if it's like, I want
to encrypt all the notes
from the call center, but still search it,
no, that's not gonna happen.
But could I encrypt addresses
and still search across it?
Yeah, probably.
And the database,
SDK implements this for
Dynamo, that's available today.
Searchable encryption in
Dynamo is available today.
Again, it comes with a pile of asterisks
that you and your engineering
team should investigate.
But it's cool and it works.
We have customers using it.
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
- [Peter] With the AWS
database encryption SDK.
Yeah. It's pretty cool.
And you should have your
account team follow up with us.
Like the team that is working
on this kind of vanguard
of exploring stuff is
very interested in talking
to customers and hearing use cases, right?
(audience member speaks indistinctly)
Tell your account team you're interested
in having a conversation
about homomorphic encryption.
If you search the session
catalog for homomorphic,
you'll find the sessions.
I'm pretty sure Tal and Raj
are talking about it this week.
Tal Rabin, who leads that trio.
This trio of cryptographers,
they all have Wikipedia pages,
if that helps contextualize
who they are and what they're about.
Yeah, we're doing some
really cool stuff there.
- [Jenn] All right. So we've
reached the end of the time.
The red light is flashing.
So thank you all for coming.
Hope you found this very informative.
Please fill out the survey
and let us know how you liked it,
and we look forward to
talking to you guys more.
- [Peter] Cool.
(audience applauding)